[Music]
are
we find around actor
[Music]
so we've got people got no idea what a
social penetration means you have no
idea okay so this is going to teach you
second one we got scaredy-cat new kids
who once they give little boy they try
to pull out so it's going to do anything
oxen don't explode you you're just
fighting through you might stumble if
you take your damn phone
but don't go haha okay let's go
don't fit you should be shoving up
[Music]
please
so elbows in the tops enjoy dating not
Perry outside boom fallen top zero fresh
your uncle's get sharper and smaller
[Music]
Hey
hi Stacy to your father's what you
tragedy
[Music]
you made it all she got it okay you see
you're lying to yourselves all you gotta
do is take that body you've been
conditioning for years and used it just
like the damn game I saw you run over
there get that damn constant ball and
you guys can't run to get your grips
let's go yeah
[Music]
his body can't wait to see him though
and then you're going to go back to
eight you're already where do you think
okay go
[Music]
are you okay oh can I touch so what
whatever my going to be I find what I'm
you very aggressive okay
so many knives in your mouth weird it's
not in your hands and I don't like the
ice come in I don't want to grind you
you're gonna stab me okay
the guy who did I can feel now using a
crossbow go check on the one arm by but
I don't
[Music]
boy
notice what I did watch your hair
I have content I'm not going to go off
and do the first drill again you
understand excreting the athleticism
death lesson so I heard you did the
first drill right I'm gonna get him keep
your life in he should he goes he turns
he's the one pushing into me
okay go if you make contact then you
gotta do the other
[Applause]
[Music]
he goes go grab her
so you do die
[Music]
when muscles being used when push your
fault you can't tell that you're
watching it okay so it's the same thing
it's going he's gonna drop you see and
he's got it don't see to the ground by
fighting it leave the drop learn is zero
pressure on the rock that's your big
mistake well before that you trying to
fight him GBH Diego you can't deviate
I'm just checking
look what's what I'm gonna do now get
off the line pass the bar so deviate he
turns on me fast impression that's how
you pretty sure find money provided
would use quicker it's the same thing
it's all easier they iisten get smaller
and
boom but it but if you change
[Music]
the counter
okay let's try that room go
tactical it's just not okay so he goes
what I'm doing is this counter you see
just won't stick this short
come on
[Music]
because it's very hard to see what's
coming is very hard then I have the
reaction gallop scene processing
decision-making if I just maintained I
can't eat it I know this coming
[Music]
you wanna bake bake effective not even a
sparring situation they polish on it
shows up in your body are two you go
y'all got y'all keep moving
I like to the mood but you got stuff on
her keep getting your mind and stuff on
them
Bayside's of the dojo let's go
[Music]
we touch okay this is what I bought
it's not right same thing when you drop
are we not touching we are touching okay
say donors don't Falls don't get rid of
the zero pressure so they're any good he
has to drop do you understand it's not
try to pull it next our finding I've
secured the ground so hold 30 goes like
that whoa how do you go when I feel like
that pull that in it okay I feel like I
pull that's not it
just like here we get this is not it
zero questions okay boom go to ground
zero pressure zero questions okay so you
got it don't start let him have the rock
oh you'll find where to go ideally I'm
going to do this with the principles no
shade once he hit the ground does not
change
okay let's try it
[Music]
the drill was I don't like this person
turns on me you passed me on the steps
don't don't don't try it out Hey okay
here she goes that's why we're connected
it's not this you goes flying by me and
then I'm turning together damn she
coming in full turn it again take it out
take a fly pocket they go flying back
okay okay you're trying to get somebody
who already miss you is your fear
cycling right okay go
[Music]
[Applause]
predetermined woman can be on a man can
begin okay so a tactic can be young
that was looks like a yin tactic and
what looks like a dog tactic can be a
gin tactic okay so he goes to grab me
and I'm back here this is a young tactic
he has all of the aggression and the
resistance and the rejection yet
acceptance he goes again do you see
okay so the same thing when I'm here
that's I went off but that's like long
can you feel that
okay so the same thing he's pushing and
this is me but yet so you must see
energetically don't they call immunity
you're not young the hell out of that
thing you reject the existing you're not
lending threading the needle
do you understand you're not
disappearing you kind of cost you the
same thing
that's a good variation okay so free
your mind get out of economy okay try to
get is we're gonna pick it up and you're
gonna have to get free of the dichotomy
[Music]
get out okay
Oh
[Music]
he'll come back
push again try to get you're gonna feel
the tension release it I don't even
invite it
[Music]
but it's the same thing
contact you finances yeah China get rid
of the legend the drum
[Music]
like mostly release me emotionally
in your mind you want him to stop you
want release external okay you almost
would tap out if you could its internal
the pressures stop because internally
you're pressing back so your releases
you want is internal it's you
we don't need mercy because we dismantle
the pushing the dummy on pressure contra
by taking ourselves out of it
[Music]
[Applause]